buildin bro is the brave leader of the
losers Club that fights Pennywise to
avenge his brother and Georgie in the
book bill isn't written to be as much of
a good person as he is in the movies
stick around to the end of this video to
find out why it's the ancient evil that
terrorized Derry Maine singled out one
individual opponents above all others
and that was Bill den bro bill was the
leader of the losers Club a name given
to the group of 12 year olds who decided
to take on it by the town bully Henry
Bowers my name is Andy mushiya @d and
today on horror history we'll be
covering the main protagonist of it and
his short-lived little brother George
despite his speech crippling stutter
bill was probably the bravest character
in the book but he wasn't always that
way to understand how bill came to be
let's take a look back to the birth of
big bill in 1946 Derry hydroelectric
workers actin bro and classical pianist
Sharon Dunn Brown gave birth to their
first son William who would eventually
go by a nickname bill at a young age
bill was in a minor car accident which
his mother believed to be the cause of
his stutter but it's unclear if that's
actually true bill had a very close
relationship with his parents when he
was young and that bond was only
strengthened when Zack and Sharon gave
birth to their second son George in 1951
though they did not always get along
bill cared deeply for George and George
loved and looked up to his older brother
in October of 1957 when Georgie was 6
bill was sick in bed and used this free
time to make a paper craft boat for his
brother to play with in the rain Georgie
was thrilled that his brother would do
this for him and took special care not
to lose the boat so when the current
swept it away to the intersection of
which him in Jackson Street and Georgie
took after it the boat fell into a storm
drain and Georgie was disappointed to
lose the boat that his brother had
worked so hard to make for him then he
heard a voice inside of the drain and
saw a man in clown makeup standing there
the man introduced himself as penny wise
and tried to get Georgie to come down in
the sewers with him by offering balloons
candy and rides Georgie said he has to
go but when penny wise showed him the
boat he decided to stay for a little bit
long when you're down here with me
you'll float to the clown told to
Georgie as you reached for it and
Pennywise ripped off his arm ending the
boy's life prematurely at age six this
event had a huge effect on bill for the
rest of his life and this feeling stuck
with him even after he had forgotten how
his brother had died in December of that
same year bill snuck into Georgie's room
to look at his photo album and he
thought he saw something move in one of
the photos but still wasn't quite sure
if it was his imagination
Georgie's death had a negative effect on
Bill's relationship with his parents his
mother gave up playing the piano after
Georgie's funeral and the void he sat in
between his parents when they all sat on
the couch together felt longer and
colder without Georgie also there next
to him one day his parents got into a
fight when his father tried to remove
the toys out of Georgie's room and they
both ended up sobbing in separate rooms
paying no attention to how this was
affecting bill one could come to the
conclusion that because of this awkward
home life and Bill started spending more
time out of the house and he became
pretty good friends with an asthmatic
kid named Eddie Casper one day eight
months after his brother's funeral bill
and Eddie were playing in the Barrens
when three bullies Victor Chris Bell
Huggins and Henry Bowers came running up
to the embankments and asked if they had
seen a fat boy anywhere the boys
destroyed the dam that bill and Eddie
had been building and beat up Eddie
giving him a bloody nose and it has no
time after the bullies left bill meets
the boy that they were looking for Ben
Hanscom and asked if he'll stay with
Eddie while he tries to go get his
medicine he grabs his bike silver who
he's named after the horse from The Lone
Ranger and when he rides silver he
becomes like a new person which
resembles his adult self he rides fast
but with reckless abandon and I think
without the power that silver holds he
would likely have been struck dead in
traffic Bill's stutter is so bad that he
must write the request to the pharmacist
on a piece of paper in order to get
Eddie's aspirator when he gets back
they're amazed at how quickly he made
the run and Bill and Eddie become
friends with Ben bonding over their
beatings at the hands of Henry
that day bill decided to take another
look at Georgie's photo album he's been
starting to have visions of Georgie as a
monster which I think are a result of
its trying to rattle bill hoping he
could be a future targets bill flips to
Georgie's school photo and winks at him
causing him to drop the book and blood
it drips out of the pages though Bill's
parents would not be able to see the
blood
the next day bill helps construct the
dam at the stream and the Barons and
introduces Richie Tozier and Stan Urist
to bat as they all relax by the stream
bank bill tells the group that he needs
to tell them something serious and tells
the story about the photo this is part
of what makes him the leader of the
group
I mean they've all seen the influence of
penny wise but none of them are brave
enough to acknowledge it and talk about
it because that makes it real none of
them besides bill who must resent the
bravery because he's sick of tiptoeing
around the subject it was the brothers
killer bill doesn't know it's related to
penny wise or the murders at this point
though and he thinks it has something to
do with Georgie's ghost they're
interrupted by mr. Nell the Irish cop
who tells them that their dam is
disrupting the drainage system in Derry
bill tries to take the blame but each
one of them shares part of the blame
this is an indicator of Bill's
selflessness which comes into play for
him later on bill and Ritchie walk home
together and Richie asked if he can see
the photo album bill originally says no
but after a heartfelt conversation with
Richie he agrees a small hint about the
power that the losers Club can gain when
they're united when they go into
Georgie's room Richie is able to see the
blood-stained pages
Georgie's photo is missing instead
there's a picture of downtown Derry from
the olden days
a pair of sailors walk down the street
and they have Richie and Bill's faces
the picture begins to move and they turn
towards the canal where a clown pops up
from over the edge like a
jack-in-the-box but with Georgie's face
he reaches towards the sailor bill and
the real bill reaches his hand into the
photo before Richie Yanks his arm out
and Bill's hand is bleeding
I'd interpret this as a warning sign
from its to bill he wants bill to draw
that association between the murder of
his brother and what he perceives as the
monster because that's gonna make bill
more afraid than he was before and
Pennywise feeds off of fear
however bill doesn't shy away from the
challenge as it expects early on in the
summer bill is not able to join the
others and seeing Iowa's a teenage
werewolf at the movie theater because
he's busy taking a speech therapy test
in Bangor his mother would continually
urge him to repeat the phrase he thrusts
his fist against
posts but still insists he sees the
goats this is something that theater
performers commonly used to warm up and
it's supposed to help bill overcome and
stutter but he's also able to use it to
overcome other things such as fear
doubts or evil so bill misses the
werewolf movie but he does get to
experience the werewolf anyway when he
and Ritchie go to investigate the
abandoned house at 29 at niebolt streets
bill brings with a pistol that he stole
from his father but it isn't that
effective against it which uses the
werewolf form and wears it dary high
school jackets bill accuses it of
killing his brother to which it responds
I'll kill you too it ends up chasing
them down the streets and they try to
escape on silver but it's now in the
form of the clown but still wearing the
Derry high school jacket continues to
gain ground on them until they get near
a busy street and it disappears the
event is traumatizing for bill but it
does give him a clue he needs to help
take the fights directly to Pennywise
after the altercation at Twentynine knee
bolts bill and Ritchie looked back as
they were escaping on silver to discover
that Pennywise had just disappeared next
to a storm drain I think bill was
probably the only one who could have put
this together along with the location
where his brother Georgie was found to
determine that it is somehow connected
to the sewers he asked his father who
works for Derry hydroelectric and he
explains that the pipes are mostly empty
except for during the spring floods he
also tells them to stay out of the
sewers warning him that he could easily
get lost in there bill does some
research of his own and on July 3rd
after getting together with the losers
at the barons he explains his findings
that several other cultures seem to have
different versions of its the Irish have
a creature known as a glamour the Plains
Indians have the mana Tao the Himalayans
have the talus even though I thought
that was only in breadth of the wild
Central Europe has the Alec and the
French have the Lupe garu he explains
that the Himalayans used something
called the ritual of chewed to defeat
their talents they would overlap tongues
and then bite in so they're stapled I -
I they must then tell jokes and riddles
back and forth and the first laugh loses
the rule is simple
yeah actually felix is kind of right and
I think I just died if the human loses
he dies but if the talus loses he must
go away for 100 years so at this point
Bill started gathering up tick-tock
videos to show to Pennywise during the
ritual okay I think I died again on July
3rd the losers get together and shoot
off some firecrackers but bill tells
them to put him away because he senses
something is gonna happen
I think this is bill using the shine
which is the psychic clairvoyance that
comes up in a lot of Stephen King novels
most prominently Danny Torrance from the
shine I think they all probably shine a
little bit but Bill's is the strongest
and it's actually kind of ties in to the
reason that he has to be the one to
perform the ritual of should he tells
his friends to create a stash of rocks
because he feels like bowers and the
bullies are going to attack and what
ensues becomes known as the apocalyptic
rock fights
bill plays a big role in it by not
flinching away from the notorious
fastball pitcher Victor Kriss and
hitting him with a rock that causes him
to run from the fights the losers talk
more about how penny wise can be
defeated as they build their new
clubhouse in the Barons that July where
bill develops a theory that they can
kill the monster using a silver bullet
if something that works in the movies
and as kids they all believe that it
actually works and they go to the
library to research more methods bill
also contributed to the completion of
the clubhouse by secretly borrowing some
of his father's tools from the garage
after completing it Mike Hanlon brings
his father's old photo book to show them
how penny wise is scattered throughout
Jerry's history and one of the pages
comes to life and Pennywise rushes them
and hangs on a lamppost in the
foreground threatening to kill them all
everyone is trauma stricken by the
encounter stan is so deeply affected
that he goes into denial about it even
happening but if you analyze bill's
reaction it's different than everyone
else sure he's shaken up by what
happened but he also feels that it's is
scared of them
on July 17 the losers are seeking advice
on how to fight it and they decide to
perform this Indian smoke hole ritual in
their Clubhouse the idea was that they
did breathe in the smoke and have
visions that would help them
I think the homeless population in LA
has a similar strategy and I don't think
it works as they're trying to decide
who's gonna be the one to do it bill
shows his leadership and protect
Vaness of Beverly by arguing that it
shouldn't be heard because she's a girl
they all pick out a match and whoever
gets the burned one is supposed to stay
up top and pull him to safety if anyone
passes out however and they all pull
matches and none of them are burned
anymore
so they take the hints that they should
all go into the smoke hole bill stays in
as long as he can and sees the inside of
the tiny clubhouse start to expand to
the size of a ballroom but eventually he
can't take it anymore and he's the fifth
one to jump out it was definitely the
biggest threat to its but it just goes
to show that he wasn't strong enough
without the shared power of his friends
on July 20th after Eddie's arm got
broken by Henry Bowers bill gathers up
the gang to go visit him in the hospital
where Eddie's overprotective mother
ambushes them and tells them off they
wait out that night to try again in the
meantime developing the plan to melt
down some silver dollars to use his ammo
for Bill's slingshot from what I
understand silver dollars were much
bigger back then than they are now so it
actually could have been effective
however Bill himself wasn't such a great
shot with the slingshot you're in the
lead right now with a pathetic three at
account Ritchie depletion so it's
decided that Beverly will be the one to
handle it
it was midway through the summer no not
that midsummer when Beverly approached
the others in a panic after seeing its
take out one of the bullies
Patrick Hawk said they go to investigate
the spot in the junkyard where Beverly
saw it happen and find a threat from
Pennywise
written in blood maybe he had just had
enough of being the victim or maybe his
mind connected the side of Patrick's
blood with his own brothers but this is
where Bill snapped and screamed out
we're gonna kill you he asked his
friends desperately for their help and
they all joined together in a hug in the
rain three days later everyone goes to
Bill's place so they can make the silver
slugs and although Ben was the one
actually physically make them bill used
his creativity to help them get away
with it without his parents finding out
by setting up a Monopoly board to make
it look like they were in the middle of
the game which they could rush inside to
sit around when his parents came home
two days later they arrived at
Twentynine naval Street for the first
time since bill and Ritchie's werewolf
encounter earlier that summer Bill's
bravery and determination to avenge his
brother caused him to lead them in
crawling under the porch where they
could climb in through a basement window
it started to play tricks on them as
they made their way through one corridor
the hallway along did the eyes of the
elves on the wallpaper started to bleed
and the ceiling closed in on them
everyone to freak out perhaps it was
bills strong shine that allowed him to
stay calm and realized what they were
seeing isn't real he punches up to where
the ceiling appeared to be and when he
did so they could all see that what they
were seeing was not true and this fixes
the room the others perceived bills
strength to be a result of his love for
his brother but he reminds them that
they all have their own quirks that help
them fight back against its
manipulations eventually they make it to
a door and big bill is the first to
approach it he hears pumping machinery
coming from the other side just like the
sound of the pumping stations or as they
call them more lock holes in the Barons
I think bill with his knowledge of the
Derry hydroelectric system acquired from
its father was the first to realize what
was behind the store this was where it
came from behind the door was a
dilapidated bathroom but this was no Saw
movie this was where it's connected to
the world on the surface they were
attacked by it once again in the
werewolf form Beverly missed her first
shot and it's spring at Bill knowing he
was the leader and seeing the chance to
demoralize the group Ben steps in front
and it ends up slashing Ben before
Beverly hits it on her third and final
shots causing it to scream death threats
at them as it retreated into the sewers
Beverly's blouse is damaged and bill
offers her his shirts to cover up once
again showing the seedlings of their
attraction and Bill's protective nature
which we would see more of when
everything went down a couple weeks
later on a mysteriously quiet day in
August Ritchie
Eddie and Stan run into bill with his
bike in the middle of town
Mike later shows up too when all of a
sudden Ben and Beverly are running up to
them telling of how Henry Bowers had
snapped and chased Beverly and they were
now skulking about in the Barrens bill
makes the decision for the group they're
going to reclaim their place ponds it
was at this remark that Eddy started to
think that Henry wasn't the only one who
was losing it bill was drifting towards
madness as well if we analyse his
character up to this point he's driven
by the desire for revenge for his
brother's death crippled by grief for
his friends and classmates and shaped by
all the adult situations he's already
had to face at age 12
he's even subconsciously ridden his bike
in a dangerous way through busy streets
a very subtle beginning of suicidal
tendencies so it's likely that Eddie was
right and bill was starting to lose his
sanity
little bit that summer but unlike Henry
Bowers bill was able to get a grip on it
and actually use it to his advantage to
write horror novels as an adult they go
into the Barrens and get attacked by
rocks thrown by Victor and Belle at this
point bill realizes that it is the
biggest source of what's wrong with
Derry and asked Ben to lead them to the
pumping station that connects to the
sewers Eddy's arm is broken so bill
carries him on his back down the ladder
they shake Henry Bowers and go into the
inflow pipe underground an image that
would stick with bill through the years
and end up in one of his horror novels
the black rabbits they venture into the
dark in a line keeping one hand on the
shoulder of the person in front of them
to stay together and unknowingly
following the path of the paper boats
that bill made for Georgie almost a year
ago now they come across a small door
leading to the lair of it bill is unable
to see its true form and interprets it
as a giant spider bill is the one to
cross the room towards the spider it
tells him that it is eternal and eater
of worlds bill is heaved across the
chamber into this blackness the cosmos
of the universe he faced off against it
on something described as the ballroom
floor of eternity he was thrust by it
deep into the macro verse and although
Georgie's physical form had long since
deceased he could feel his brother had a
place in a macro verse bill was caught
by another celestial force called the
turtle who didn't want to engage in the
dispute but did give Bill the advice he
needed by telling him to thrust his
fists against the post and still insist
he sees the ghost the speech therapy
technique that bill could often be heard
using the ritual of chid doesn't happen
in the movie but there is a little
reference to it with this line
mr. dan suppose he sees the ghost he
trusts against as the human voice of it
fades out the alien language of the dead
lights the true form of its fades in
bill establishes a mental connection by
biting into its metaphysical Tommy and
using the teeth of his mind and begins
the ritual of child although bill
shouldn't have been able to stand a
chance it was his belief in all of the
childish things he believes in like the
silver bullets the power of the bike and
the phrase he thrusts his fists against
the person stolen sisty sees the ghost
that helped him overcome it it's causing
it to scream and a beg for bill to let
it go they returned to the real world
where its retreats further into the
chamber the losers decide that it
sounded like it was dying but bill was
unsure what's the thing they try to flee
before the pipes fill up with rainwater
and drown them but get lost on the way
out and bill remembers his father
warning him to never play in the sewers
because he could easily get lost
but eventually they do make their way
out of the sewers where the sky is
starting to clear up this would be the
last time all seven of them were ever
together in the same place at the same
time again and the leader of the losers
Club would make one more request that
would forever change the course of their
lives he asked them to promise that if
it were to ever come back no matter
where they were they would return and
try to kill it again they make a Blood
Pact before breaking off one by one and
returning home when bill leaves he
thinks he never wants to play in the
Barrens again just like when bill would
ride on silver defeating its opened
those gates towards adulthood
over the next year bill would lose his
stutter and it was gone by the age of 13
one by one the group moved out of Derry
wil attended a college in Maine to study
literature listing influences like Edgar
Allen Poe HP Lovecraft and Richard
Matheson he's a C student occasionally
able to earn a beating one day he calls
out his pretentious instructor in front
of the class why does the story have to
be socio anything politics culture
history aren't those natural ingredients
of any story if it's told well I mean
can't you guys just let his story be a
story you know what bill yes but I'm
still not gonna delete my channel the
instructor has a much ruder reaction
though humiliating him in front of the
class and suggesting that he has a great
deal to learn that week bill writes a
story called to the dark about a small
boy who kills the monster lurking in his
cellar I'm not sure if he realizes he's
told his own story about defeating the
monster under dairy and downscaled it to
a single house level because at this
point some of his memories about dairy
Georgie and it's have already started to
fade the teacher gives him an F and
calls it pulp crap so bill decides to
send it to a magazine where it receives
praise he sends his feed back to his
instructor alongside his drop card then
during his senior year he writes a novel
and gets it published at the age of 23
he's already a successful writer he
starts dating his agent Susan Brown and
works on a second novel called the black
Rapids which he sells the movie rights
to and has the option to do the first
draft of the screenplay
after which he's invited out to
Hollywood for further rewrites Susan
begs him not to go but he ends up
leaving Maine for the West Coast an
actress named Audra Phillips is cast in
the movie and Bill ends up marrying her
he would go on to write more novels
based on the titles of his books I think
they're all the results of the
horrifying experiences that he had as a
child the dark and the black Rapids
could be about the journey through the
sewers the glowing refers to the dead
lights the true form of EDS
though that one could also be a parody
of the shining there's also a werewolf
novel whose title is not mentioned which
could come from the werewolf form of its
that they battled he also has an
original screenplay called attic room
possibly about the encounter he had at
29 kneeble Street with the others
Bill's life is going great he's
successful he's married to a superstar
and he's long forgotten about the
traumatic childhood he had in dairy all
is well until 1985 when his old buddy
Mike Hanlon calls him up on the phone
while bill is shooting a movie in
England with some horrible news it has
returned
[Applause]
[Music]
after Mike fills bill in on everything
remnants of his childhood reemerge in
the 39 year old bill den bergh his
stutter comes back scars appear on his
hands where the Blood Pact was made and
he remembers for the first time in years
how his little brother Georgie truly
died but not all of the memories come
back right away he abandons the
production to board a plane to the US
and suddenly it seems apparent that all
the inspiration for all of his horror
novels was dairy on the cab ride over
from his hotel to the restaurant that
they're all meeting at Bill's
apologetically foul mouthed cabbie who
by the way is probably my favorite
character in the book and deserves his
own episode of horror history points out
how dairy has become more of a small
City over the years by this point
everyone already knows about how Stan
offed himself but when he enters the
room with the five remaining losers club
members bill feels that there's a sixth
somehow perhaps a clue that despite
losing most of his memories about his
childhood he seems to have retained a
little bit of his shine and no I'm not
talking about his now bald head Mike
starts explaining about the murders that
caused him to believe that it was back
and when he tells about the death of
Adrian Mellon and Bill is the only one
to realize that the one who pulled up
his body
Harold Gardner was the son of David
Gardner the man who found Georgie Mike
also tells of another death where police
found a photograph of Georgie which is
found near the body and Bill realizes
that it's the same photo that
disappeared from the album when he was a
kid at the end of the meal bill gets a
bad feeling about the fortune cookies
which I found similar to the bad feeling
he got before the rock fights in 1958
the contents of each of their cookies is
specific to their fears bill doesn't
open his but he can tell that it's a
mutant fly like from the George language
story the fly which scared bill a lot do
we have a clip of the movie
[Music]
mike has them walked the town and tried
to regain some of their old memories and
Bill meets a kid with a skateboard who
tells him that he heard changing voices
coming from one of the pipes near a
pumping station and warns him to stay
away the kids seemed surprised that
Bill's privies the thing that haunts
Derry I think bill and his friends are
unlike other adults in town because they
made the promise in 1958 bill asked to
try out the kids skateboard but at the
last second decides not to and the scene
is symbolic of how bill no longer has
the childlike energy that got him
through the encounter with it the first
time he continues walking and then asks
a little girl what her favorite store in
dario's and she tells him it's
secondhand Rose second-hand clothes he
goes over and sees his old bike silver
in the window and for the first time in
a long time he thinks about the phrase
he thrusts his fist against the posts
and still insists he sees the ghost
after buying the bike he gets permission
to store it at Mike's house and together
they fix up the bike adding childish
adding childish adding childish I sound
like bill right now they fix up the bike
adding childish frills like playing
cards Mike opens up a new pack of cards
and it contains two ace of spades one
with a blue bag and the other red as if
this was a mixed day I think this
represents the elements of Bill's
childhood starting to manifest
themselves in the adult bill similar to
how his stutter and his old scars came
back that night after catching up with
everyone some more over some drinks at
the library and having another scary
encounter with its who uses the form of
Stan use his head to threaten the losers
Club but they call it a night starting
to feel better about their chances after
recovering more of their lost memories
before leaving Beverley starts screaming
about their hands and they realized that
all of their hands are bleeding from the
scars where they made the promise they
all hold hands as crazy supernatural
occurrences rocked the library
and bill gets the feeling that this
would be the last time all six of them
were together just like the promise they
made in 1958 it was the last time the
seven of them were together after this
happens Beverley claims that she now
remembers everything that happened in
the original battle of it and Bill is
dismal aware that he's falling in love
with above the two decided to walk back
to the hotel together Beverley asked for
a kiss and bill becomes aware of how
much she looks like Audra and kisses her
I can give Bev a pass because she just
left an abusive husband but pretty
uncool on Bill's part they end up going
back to Bill
room and they go all the way obviously
this is a pretty crappy thing to do on
bills part but in terms of what it means
for his character he's realizing that
the woman that he married is very much
like one of his first attractions when
he was younger
okay that sounds weird to say what I'm
trying to say is that Bill realizes that
he'd never actually lost the youthful
energy and the mindset that helps in
defeat it's just like how his creative
mind was a big part of his childhood and
he became a writer to continue
channeling that energy even after he had
forgotten about diary bill gets a call
from Eddie's room in the middle of the
night and shows up to find his arm
broken once again and Henry Bowers dead
in the hotel room they realize it's must
have broken out Henry and decide that
they can't wait until tomorrow they have
to kill it tonight before one of them
gets killed they call over to the
library to tell Mike but the police
chief picks up they were too late Henry
had put Mike in the hospital
the remaining five of them pile into
Eddie's limo and it's taunts bill over
the car radio each one of them had fears
as children and each of them have new
fears as adults but Bill's fear has
stayed constant he fears losing someone
that he loves ever since he lost his
brother Georgie its uses Georgie's voice
screaming things like you let it kill me
to rattle bill this wouldn't be the only
thing that it did to expose bills fear
though when they arrived at the man hall
bill finds a familiar object it's his
wife Audra's pervs
she had come after him against his
warnings and it's abducted her knowing
that bill couldn't handle losing another
loved one I mean I would say that he
shouldn't have cheated on her if that
was the case but I'm not supposed to
have an opinion bill once again has to
carry the crippled Eddie down the ladder
just as they did his children the sewer
systems have changed over the years but
the old unused pipes are still in place
and the five members of the losers Club
make their way back to the lair of it
but there would be one more challenge
for bill before they get there there
were instances back in 1958 or it's
threatened bill with one of his worst
fears claiming it's would take the form
of Georgie in order to drive bill insane
however unlike the movie it saves this
trump card for the sewers in 1985 bill
held up the match he was using to light
the way and saw Georgie approaching him
in his yellow rain jacket trying and
looking for his boat when Georgie cried
a strange garble of sounds was heard
but bill was too heartbroken to notice
that something was off bill felt that he
deserved to die
all the others can do is encourage bill
to realize that it's not really Georgie
and fight it bill stutter is hampering
not only his speech but his rationality
but he's finally able to successfully
recite the line to overcome both his
stutter and it which retreats back into
the inner layer there was only one thing
left to do now the final confrontation
with is as Bill Ben Eddie Ritchie in
Beverly get into the spiders chamber
they realized that they no longer needed
the mashes as there's something
emanating from it the deadlines the
nightmare spider descends from above and
the bill finds Audra strung up in the
webbing Phil confronts the spider and
finds himself being flung out of his
physical body and back into the void it
tells him that the turtle who helped him
in 1958 died a few years ago and won't
be of any use this time it threw him
again and Bill tried to mentally seize
its tongue and engage in the ritual of
code but this time he misses his grip
back in the actual physical chamber
Ritchie notices bills face contorting
his spirit is in another realm
so Ritchie runs up to the spider and
tries to distract it but he gets whacked
into the macro verse Ritchie is able to
engage in the ritual he takes bill's
hand and holds tightly onto it which
returns to the real world and they get
back to their physical bodies when they
arrived they find that the spider has
already maimed Eddie and he's dying but
this time they can't let it get away and
they follow it into the deepest part of
the chamber the dead light is leaking
out of it now and it begs them to let it
go offering the chance to live 500 years
but bill with his childlike innocence
only wants to see his brothers killer
brought to justice it's only fitting
that over 27 years later bill is the one
to punch his way into the spider's chest
and crush the heart with his bare
after helping Richie back to the others
bill finds his wife and discovers that
she still has a pulse but she's become
catatonic Eddie is dead and without him
they have a much harder time navigating
their way out bill is the only one to
eventually realize that there's light
coming in through small holes on the top
of the pipe the street above them had
collapsed in an epic flood that took
place while they were fighting hands and
they're able to pull themselves back up
on a Main streets
Beverly tells bill that she hopes Audra
is gonna be alright and they share one
last hug which is photographed by a
reporter documenting the damage and
appears in the newspaper with the
caption survivors Audra's taken away in
an ambulance and bill runs into the
skateboard kid from before and tells him
it's all right now at first this seems
like an insignificant interaction but I
can only imagine how good this felt for
bill after being driven to destroy the
monster under dairy for so long because
of what happened to his brother to let
this new generation know that they don't
have to be afraid anymore but with its
dead the remaining losers clubs memories
started to fade once more this time much
faster than before
within a few days bill was unable to
remember Stan's last name or Eddie's
health condition bill had one last thing
to take care of
Audra was released from the hospital
before Mike she was able to eat solid
foods now but she was still catatonic
so Mike let them stay at his house to
try to rehab but she wasn't making much
progress and bill began to fear that his
wife would be a vegetable forever he had
one more idea to try to save her
something that had saved him something
that had saved Eddie and Ritchie to his
old bike silver decked out with all of
his childhood fanfare like the playing
cards the basket and the horn
he sat audre in the carrier and did what
he had always done rode fast and
recklessly downhill into a busy streets
picking up speed instead of braking and
just like his belief in everything from
his childhood saved him once before
against its Audra comes to and holds on
to Bill who stutter has completely
disappeared and they embrace bill was
the centerpiece of the losers Club that
finally defeated the scourge of Derry
Maine laying it to rest his bravery and
leadership shined through even the
bleakest of scenarios and he was driven
all along by his love for those close to
him his wife Audra before that his best
friends Eddie rich east and Beverly in
my
through everything his little brother
Georgie
so that's the entire known history of
their dungeons your homework is to let
me know in the comments who I should
analyze next on horror history and click
the playlist on the left for my lessons
on other characters remember to
subscribe to seize these worlds for new
Horrors every week ring that death bell
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one
assuming we both survive